what is going on there reject nation
greg and john here today thank you so
much for clicking on this video we are
of course about to watch the what if
finale very very much excited for it the
last episode was phenomenal will they
deliver the goods and i want to thank
everyone who's been watching this series
with us from the beginning and all the
other marvel shows as well as always if
you end up enjoying our video go ahead
and hit that like button or the dislike
button doesn't matter which one just
vote and do consider subscribing and
clicking that notification about while
you're at it full length watch alongs
where you sync up with the time code for
whatever our patreon page where at the
same tier we got the option for both
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included lastly thank you to the boys at
prepper for editing down every one of
these highlights for us you guys are so
sexy you should be models
[Music]
they're about to send up their last
payload when pirates took the ship
winter soldier
[Music]
no helmet required
are you scared are you seeing that
heaven god
you have been chosen
dang oh my god he's recruiting his
gloves are off
come on relax son it'll all be over in a
thousand years or so oh how cool oh god
dude
stay here
leave this fight
hang back with the uh giant baby man
cape dude
star-lord t'challa you
have been chosen
oh man this is so cool he's breaking his
oath all over the place not given a
single fudge any longer
gamora survivor of sakaar and destroyer
of thanos what
not you stark you know
who have been chosen
[Music]
for murder under wakandan law killmonger
tony stark's former protege you
have been chosen you know we're going to
get star-lord t'challa and eric
killmonger
nobody messes with vegas
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm prince of
[Music]
the villain pub
the pub facade was my idea i read about
it in your biography
but it's so cool
this mission requires a team the perfect
combination of skills and experience you
aren't just our best hope to save one
universe you are
the guardians of the multiverse
and after we recover the stones we
destroy them how would you even go about
destroying the oh you're answering my
question sorry thank you the infinity
crusher oh
cool in my universe steve rogers
received the serum now that would be a
sight to see
maybe you could now
two the guardians of uh
uh
yeah let ultron
oh my
wow all right here comes the
non-compliant spell
yeah you might feel it
power up it's a protection spell you're
welcome awesome
what
it's like an impossible fight yeah
with no time to become a proper team
either
interesting usually you people are much
easier to kill
whoa
oh dope nice dope
dope
[Music]
oh shut him right away man
did he get one though
[Applause]
did you get him yes yeah
never doubt yeah
my man
[Laughter]
my stone
you stole my soul stone that was my
favorite suit i looked at them all
meticulously
[Music]
dude
nice
[Music]
zombies great idea he loves them it's
not them it's what came with the zombies
oh
yeah
eric boss predicted what came with the
zombies
[Music]
oh how twisted
[Music]
[Music]
she's natasha romanov who t'challa said
who
how day
i believe that you have something that
belongs to me
oh
oh my god it's hot potato i know
why won't you die
oh no god i love the animation that's
great animation whoa
[Music]
what
nice unload
yeah
oh cool cool
[Music]
i'm loving the fighting man it is great
[Music]
slow this down
take this all in
nice work that's gotta be a special
sound damn it reverse time oh man
ah yes
yeah time stone off
[Music]
hello me
whoa
[Music]
his ass
gamora got the solstice
you're done
[Music]
whoa
i'm honestly surprised
didn't the watcher warn you every
the shot
the avengers assemble shot
vanity stones are unique
of course the crusher was designed to
destroy the stones on my world not his
oh
that damn rule
brace yourselves yeah [ __ ] me man
dude ultron's boobs are like all hail
mary's i know
they're all finishers
if i destroy you you all fall
oh my god
oh
oh yes right yes
oh
that's cool bring it
back oh hell yeah
this one's for you clint yeah
[Music]
come on
[Music]
damn natasha
oh
this is fine
it's been a long time since i've had
legs i'd like to make this a permanent
condition this body is occupied for now
but not for long what
who are you the lawnmower man
it's about time
my objective
is to end you
what is this
falling out of the matrix yeah dead
oh what are you doing dude no oh
where are you watcher you're supposed to
be supervising the time
no
stone monger
[Music]
way to choose wisely watcher hand over
this town's cousin
i'm not your cousin
i'm sorry it has to end this way
oh damn it oh no no no i am afraid that
it belongs to me
oh no
[Music]
[Music]
we were here to separate the stones from
the body
oh
[Music]
huh
what's happened every moment from the
failed infinity crusher to killmonger's
betrayal and my
your sacrifice if that pocket dimension
cracks if they escape i'll watch
once you walk through that door you will
return to the exact moment you left
my world is gone
you won but i lost
i cannot interfere yeah
what
is he gonna
do
look at his cat marvel loki where are we
on a world that lost their widow
it's a mess
thank you all right
you and your replacement avengers fought
valiantly but now i think it's time you
told me all your secrets
nice yeah
i was told you were dead
same
oh oh
yeah
[Music]
you're not my natasha
but something tells me you have her
spirit
that's it all creatures searching for a
place to belong
to call home
thor belongs to vegas that's right man
party prince every story is my home and
i will protect it to the end
will they get an actual post credit
scene we could i mean
we'll wait out plans for seats because
it doesn't say next
god the art styles yeah across this
episode western needs to stop saying i
can't interfere i know and should change
you i won't interfere i'm sensing
this whole episode is causing
interpretation
what
i found what the pirates were after you
might want to brace yourself i can
promise you that this won't be the
strangest thing i dealt with today steve
and there's someone inside
oh wow that's for watching why you
should
watch him push your [ __ ]
watch her he knew thank god he can't
interfere that's right
that's right he's going to stick to that
as much as possible
oh yeah i feel like that's the theme of
everything upcoming is all the people
who are celestial beings whose job it is
to not interfere about to interfere all
over the place
like in chiang chi
that's right man
no she was it's a survivor of sakaar
and destroyer of thanos
somehow we just did it what if we never
saw the context of any of that i'm like
damn that would that was that would have
been a cool ass episode to check out
watching her compete in the gladiator
matches in sakaar and destroyed thanos i
would have been bomb episode yeah
especially after thanos kills her in
infinity war
that would have been very cathartic and
rewarding nah that was just the only
takeaway
that was their thanos is a [ __ ] moment
for this episode
they melt the infinity gauntlet in a
tree's little foundry and they don't
kill off iron man but they just go
you're not included at this time yeah we
don't need you buddy not you don't even
volunteer now even though in the sacred
timeline
you were the one who helped defeat this
multiversal threat yes yes yes but we
had not this time though was it
multiverse no no it wasn't at that point
it seemed like it was just the known
universe one universe yeah it's still a
universe thread either way it was a
pretty significant threat yet
yeah no no we don't need you buddy you
don't you don't want to play with us no
more we don't need you
uh but you know either way i thought
this episode was actually a lot of fun
yeah it was very thrilling i had a lot
of fun with it i mean there was such a
wide array of
just so many different and like all the
animation flourishes that
you
not that necessarily you'd expect but
they kind of managed to do a good
mishmash yeah of all the things that
made each episode
that just a little extra unique yeah and
they managed to sort of and find the
moments to infuse it
uh even if it was with the music but
mainly with like the animation touches
like i was so glad that whenever strange
supreme was doing some of his
gnarly demonic wild things that he was
able to still have the animation style
be like that of what we love so much
about episode four yeah absolutely um
but just all around it was so well done
like when the action started kicking in
with them versus ultron i was just like
wow this is great to behold and it just
kept looking cooler and cooler and
cooler i just want to really watch it
like the choreography of watching this
the multiplicity of all these powers
coming together was was awesome you know
it didn't it it kind of brought back
that feeling of when you first see the
the first avengers movie 2012 of like
damn look at them all look at all the
powers on display all of them working
together and figuring this out this is
great and then uh watching dr strange
uh shield all them with the protection
spell
i was just like super badass yeah yeah
it was very rousing it got me just
caught up in the fun of yeah having a
newly united team in a show that didn't
like even though there was a lot of
speculation because of a few trailer
shots like okay certain of them are
gonna meet up i still kind of bought
into yeah each week we're kind of seeing
yeah like a bunch of little origin
stories for who the team is eventually
going to be and then yeah this episode i
got really caught up in the fun of that
i do have a bit of a in the back of my
mind i am a bit like
these were the essential this was the
only team because it seemed like certain
people were a little more instrumental
in the victory than others but moreover
i really enjoyed everyone's chemistry
together i really enjoyed the team from
that perspective i think the most just
getting to hear them all bounce off each
other and and i think it made previous
episodes feel just a little more
rewarding too after everything because
there are a lot of fun callbacks to both
you know the movies as they've been
doing and also the show itself which is
fun well a lot of them picked up from
either the ending moments of their
respective episodes or the cliffhangers
yeah um like with t'challa and star-lord
picked up right from there and sometimes
some of them you get like an outcome of
or a wrap up on other ones you kind of
leave on a note of oh we can we could
still do a sequel to this episode right
maybe we still do a part two to this
episode right you know
um well i like that this almost became
part two to the zombies episode after a
while because it's like they dump all
the zombies on them and then they go
back to the ravaged zombie planet and
like yeah it was fun that they actually
brought
more i thought they brought more around
yeah than i was expecting them to
ultimately bring around i didn't think
they would bring as much into it as they
did yeah i thought when they were like
pulling them from other universes we
wouldn't pick up from
like the cliffhangers or the aftermath
like with killmonger's episode you know
you see shuri and you see pepper and
they're marching and they're like we
gotta you know i forget what they say
we're gonna get revenge or some [ __ ]
yeah we gotta put them on trial or you
know we gotta take care of them before
the americans get their hands on them
yeah so they had that moment and then
thor just went back to vegas to keep
fighting just to keep yeah
he's like i'm taking this fight to vegas
that's right i'm going to defend my new
favorite place in the capital you have
to go there like he returns and he goes
right back to vegas yeah this is what
he's doing the party principal so he's
like we had a date and then when he
shows the reunion with jane
it's back in vegas in mexico yeah yeah
well i loved it he still got chosen to
be you know a multiversal avenger even
though he doesn't really grow up or
learn much
no no no
i mean i i will admit like
i wasn't fully
buying in 100 or at least like
really finding myself um swept up or
loving it until the action actually
started happening yeah before that i was
like okay we're back to like the
whiplash fast-paced base that uh i'm not
that that's the thing that makes me go
like oh come on it's your finale you
could have spent a little more time you
could have added like 10 more minutes
today deliciousness i know this is like
a few more minutes longer than the other
ones this came in at the run time of 36
minutes
uh or 35 versus like usually
30.
credits included so it's really a bit
less than that yeah yeah but i still
thought this could have been like your
45-minute finale or something like that
that way we could really spend some time
with
them getting to know each other and
getting acquainted with the situation
and really feel like the the chemistry
and their bond truly forming and i'd be
curious to know if you guys uh don't
have that desire or that wish and you
actually thought it worked just fine for
you or just perfect because for me i
thought it was missing a tad bit of that
just extra just living in it
with them a little bit more and you like
the first avengers when they're just you
know they're all hanging out part of the
fun is the them getting to know each
other and bicker and banter properly or
whatever the hell they did the quippy
marvel
well that and also room to create
tension because there is a certain like
they they they compensate for it in the
scope of the immediacy of the battling
yeah and they work together well
right away yeah and i feel like part of
the fun of the team ups
can be like oh they're not really
they're different things they learn how
to do they gotta learn how to work with
the team yeah but instead they start
getting a pretty good handle
on it pretty fast yes even though like
the fight goes on for a while and as
crazy cool as it looked and i thought
they really took advantage of their
animation medium yeah i loved the
aesthetics of it so much
um
however
yeah it was when you like kind of look
back on the fight like well they they
see like for the most part they were
pretty much
pretty much
we're just progressively winning
throughout
yeah yeah i mean as cool and awesome as
that armor isn't as much as you're like
they they need that they need that for
sure because of how you know a powerful
all-powerful ultron infinity is but at
the same time
it does kind of create this thing where
yeah they're just on the offensive all
the time they're not really getting hurt
uh and you know there's big destruction
around them but ultimately i think it it
helps that they have that fake out of
you know oh we thought we did it by
stealing the stone and they make such a
big thing out of the stone and the stone
dropping like they did a lot of
cinematic stuff to counter to
counterbalance that lack of maybe
dynamic breathing room and then yeah i
ultimately appreciated that switcheroo
where it's like oh damn that's not
what's gonna work and actually we've got
to bring back the zola arrow of course
that is going to go uh even more bonkers
because once he gets you know inside the
ultron body of course he's gonna want
pretty much the same thing and then of
course killmonger is gonna go on his
path to ultimate realization and he's
gonna try and take the stones so like
i thought they brought it to a
conclusion that was like interesting and
fun in a way that again got me not
thinking so much about yeah it's they
come together really easily and kind of
just fight until they win yeah i wasn't
even thinking about that until we
started talking about it yeah i know it
wasn't really something that occurred in
my mind in the immediacy of experiencing
the episode
like as we were watching it i was once
the action started i was very much
enveloped in everything that was
happening oh yeah and i i thought like
maybe that's that's probably what we
would want most without it with the
animation medium is for them to visually
realize just that awesome sequence
together them like seeing the necessity
of having all these people fight ultron
specifically
uh yeah but you know you can't help but
look back and go ah some moments could
have just lasted longer or you could
have deliberate deliberated over a few
things a little bit more
like killmonger
taking the stones like i thought i
presented a good argument i'm like you
know i could see the the the temptation
here it's just like boring here in the
ring he's like we could do so much good
with this you guys and i thought like i
would have been cool if they just like
you know discussed it a little bit or
argued over it like some people were
kind of forward and some weren't you
know yeah exactly because i just wanted
the remake of avengers i wanted the loki
scepters
i get you though because it's like on
the one hand you're like well
it's like if peggy had posed that i'm
like
maybe everyone would have gone along
with it because it's it's because
killmonger is posing the idea where
you're like oh no this is just a ploy to
get everybody to let you leave with the
stones yeah but like yeah it it is
something that does deserve i think or
could have done with or benefited from
some extra exploration because yeah like
they all come from these worlds that are
being like torn apart and stuff like
that and if they could replenish them
but also i mean it's it's fully within
the fitting of the show of you know
every time something is triumphed over
all of a sudden a new threat shows up so
you know it would perpetuate that cycle
because i thought there were some good
ethics debates they could have had
especially when peggy does go don't i
deserve to
have my love and go back yeah when and
he's like i can't interfere i'm like but
she did just
really help out she saved the
multi-verses you're interfering yeah
yeah
and you didn't even butt in that much
you could have interfered in the mission
a little bit i thought i was gonna get
involved in the fight himself yeah
especially after the last episode
uh but i i still thought like it was a
really cool fight and i do love that
they didn't make every episode feel
essential like even with black widow i
thought that was actually a really
strong resolution
um to put pluck her from her apocalyptic
episode and put her into the episode for
it was episode three yeah right when
everyone was murdered
you know
um
kicking ass yeah he just wins
yeah because
he shows up at the at the at the ice and
then captain marvel shows up behind him
yeah and then there's loki and
yeah you know
like those
those scenes but even like nick fury's
just so uh
you're not from my earth all right yeah
but i know that you got her spirit so
you're basically hurt let's go like this
was their one plot i think
that could have been your short movie
your your 80 minute
because it's so big and it's it's tying
so much in together
that while in the immediacy of it i was
having such a kick-ass time with it like
i was really really enjoying it a lot
it's this weird dichotomy that when we
sit down to talk about it because we
have to do a couple of things and then
10-15 minutes later we're finally
talking about it and now that we're
talking about i'm like here's something
okay i do kind of wish we got a little
bit more of this yeah this little thread
so that's that's the idea of doing a
reaction and then reviewing it
except now we had a little bit of a
breather now we're talking about it
because it is a really fun episode like
in the in the immediate moment of first
watching it i was just fully swept up in
the pace and the rhythm and everything
but yeah it's it's weird because it's
it's that thing of like leave them
wanting more except in this case i think
they should have just gone a little
further each time well if captain carter
is rumored to be in uh doctor strange
multiverse of madness
the if she is indeed brought to life
does that give us the possibility of a
steve rogers there's gotta be or they're
just gonna reference they could just
bring it i mean they pro what i would
expect is for them to just reference him
but hey i mean if she is the same
captain you know because there's got to
be multiple captain carters too but if
it's this particular one who has just
discovered yeah that uh the hydra
stomper is here and there's a steve
inside then why not and i like that uh
after
i like that it's like you end her story
here
where she gets a chance to reunite with
her love likewise captain america his
story and the mcu ended with him getting
to reunite with his love too
they're just destined to be together
it's an absolute point
yeah in time for them to be with each
other it's weird how these resolves come
around and then you have like black
widow who almost feels like she's had
more resolves in this series that feel
weightier than the entire black men in
the movie
yeah and i thought it was great that
they brought back the whole hawkeye
thing too that's what i mean they didn't
just bring back like easter eggs or nods
or whatever they
they they don't tell you up front that
this is all going to tie together yeah
so it's cool when you're watching this
one episode you're like oh [ __ ] it all
does time again every episode unless i'm
there's an episode i'm not factoring in
but i'm pretty sure they all died again
everything ties together in some fashion
it seems like yeah yeah
even if some are like way more not
missing in here right i don't think so
let's go over them each in great detail
first episode was carter second episode
star-lord cachala third episode the
murder mystery with a yellow jacket
fourth episode the strange supreme fifth
episode
zombies
the zombies came back yeah and then six
was killmonger killmonger yeah i want to
say and then seven was party three party
thor and then this yeah okay so
everything together there's not one
we're missing right there's eight yeah
this was nine
no this is nine this in squid game both
are nine episode seasons
yes it's the it's the year of the nine
episode season here we go i feel like
we're we're missing one episode
other than the old tron episode yeah
yeah the last one really is directly
into this one yeah they'll try it yeah
there's one we're missing yeah
i mean i wonder if and i don't think it
would ultimately alleviate because each
episode individually we've had these
kinds of issues but i wonder what it
would be like to watch the previous
episode in this one in one go because
they are the two episodes that directly
feed with no kind of prior be like even
the end of party thor has like that what
what what is this but then at the
beginning of the next episode he's just
business as usual yeah so like to watch
them back to back i wonder if that might
feel a little bit more like that you
know 80 minute animated movie experience
or an hour-long movie experience i think
it might have worked a tad bit better if
they had planted the seed for ultron a
little bit earlier in the show
instead of like okay end of party thor
in the next one
end of yeah end of all the individual
episodes and then you introduce like the
thing that will immediately make
everything serialized all of a sudden
yeah you could like utilize post-credits
scenes for for such a case or something
like that yeah yeah or had some kind of
you could have even like laced in some
kind of way he's collecting the stones
across the episodes
somehow yeah build to it yeah it'd be
true it would be tricky but if they had
done it it would have been impressive
yeah it would have been impressive
and yeah especially um one thing with
the stakes too is that they after they
after the last episode where it's like
ultron it seems impossible to defeat
yeah and then here is like
you're in real time with the fight and
it's like a 20-minute fight no it really
it really is and it's funny because you
know it's like you you get that one
reversal but it still is like oh man you
know all you got to do is just this one
thing and he's done for he's done yeah
you know and i mean again they i think
they counterweight it nicely with this
whole thing of like okay well steven's
gotta just watch this thing forever and
make sure they never break out but still
it is a little bit like
oh i i guess you know a few of you
most of whom don't actually have like
magical powers uh yeah
all you got to do is get him in a
position where you can punch him a bunch
but great life and great fighting and
great choreography
and uh i love the use of the stones too
especially like i love like the time
stone off that they had in one moment
yeah and i thought they had like fun
little easter eggs like plenty
throughout this whole episode from
beginning to end yeah even some subtler
ones like with star lord going
i'm black i'm natasha or that's or
whatever and then he goes who
yeah
that's hilarious russell showed up to do
one line yeah yeah you pick up from that
and you see that star-lord does survive
yeah or peter quill does survive and
then you got fighting with the child
yeah at the end there yeah they had a
lot of fun stuff here so overall this is
one of those episodes that i really do
feel is
ultimately serviceable it pays off the
commitment to watching all the other
episodes i love that it all ties in and
while i pretty much everything that i'm
was wanting was like i wish this was
longer so they could flush out more of
this stuff and let this breathe and
build up the stakes you know other
things that are more like emotional
engaging in terms of being like worried
or concerned or
uh just having some more of that
character development stuff but i still
gave us character development in a lot
of areas that i wasn't ultimately
expecting them to do
so overall i'm pretty satisfied with
this episode i mean i probably
it's not
not like my favorite obviously uh not my
favorite it's not the strange one still
still my favorite strange episode is so
good yeah yeah i mean that that one
is kind
a lot of these have had aspects of like
all the things i was hoping this series
could be ah but that one i think nails
every the heights of what i hoped of
this series could be with all the
breathing room i hoped it could be
afforded yeah that one was pretty much
near perfect yeah and uh this one i was
like i wish this was like a movie yeah
yeah yeah it was the one that i was like
i wish this was a movie yeah because
this would have been well right i think
i just would have stuck around yeah it's
really cool disney plus at midnight like
oh my god this is an hour and 20 minutes
oh yeah you feel like you're getting a
big treat because it's really cool it's
really fun and then having it be like an
extra jumbo episode like that would be
yeah so dazzling but as it stands
overall i did enjoy this series i don't
think i personally don't find it better
than the other
marvel shows that we got this year but i
don't think anyone was really expecting
this to be better although you might
disagree so let us know if you actually
like it more than falcon and winter
soldier wander vision or
loki um
but yeah overall
i'm satisfied i liked it i tuned in for
a season too yeah that's a lot of fun
absolutely i think they've got a lot to
build on
oh definitely and i think hopefully they
take some notes into account of what
some people have said about the show oh
yeah
it take a few notes let it breathe and
then just go even crazier next time
because that's a common consensus is
because a lot of the time people were
thinking like i don't feel like this
show is really consequential or
important or has any say so it's just a
synthology
um and that's why i think like lacing it
with like clueing people in earlier that
this is all gonna connect yeah would
have helped with feeling like the
significance of this yeah yeah and uh
and and i do think a lot of people have
i know way more than our than just us
have talked about that most episodes
they feel like should have a longer run
time yeah so i know we're not the only
ones who have said that but as it stands
uh yeah still enjoyed it guys leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that
bell hit that like button